[Music]
we started getting some visitors from
every universe hello peter it's been
very nice to come back to something that
is familiar but at the same time
completely new you're not peter parker i
am so confused right now 20 years since
his green goblin
17 years since my first time as doc what
was your name again dr otto octavius
seriously what's your actual name you
got another chance to stir some things
up oh you like the new new electro is
like the world did me wrong now i got
this energy i'm about to go get mine you
know take this away from me
picks up where he left off what have you
done with my machine he's looking for
revenge do you want to play games
the goblin believes in a world of losers
and winners power is all that matters
[Music]
it's a wonderful world to be in we're
having a lot of fun they're a danger to
our universe we need to send them back
looks like we got competition
i think people are going to be really
surprised they're going to marvel
oh
ever since i got bit by that spider
i've only had one week
where my life has felt normal
that was when you found out
[Music]
when you botched that spell where you
wanted everyone to forget the peter
parker spiderman
we started getting some visitors
[Applause]
from every
universe
hello peter
you're not peter parker
i'm sorry what was your name again dr
otto octavius
[Laughter]
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
there are others out there we need to
send them back
so
scooby scooby-doo this crap
you know all this is kind of your mess i
know a couple of magic words myself
starting with the word please
please
scooby-doo this crap
you're flying out into the darkness
to fight ghosts what do you mean
they all die fighting spider-man
it's their fate
i'm sorry kid
yeah me too
don't
but there has to be another way there
isn't
they're a danger to our universe
you know how to take this away from me
peter
you're struggling
and everything you want
while the world tries to make you choose
this is all my fault i can't save
everyone
[Applause]
what's happening they're starting to
come through
and i can't stop them
december 17th exclusively in movie
theaters tickets on sale november 29th
spider monday
[Music]
you